Do you leverage your initial leads to multiple business owners to get more of them on the hook?
So Rudy, I've done, I've kind of tried both ways.
I prefer to stick with one business owner because again, remember what I said to
Jean or yeah, to Jeannie said, talk about retention, which by the way, Eugene or sorry,
Jean, your issue, you need to get these guys in a contract.
I think that's going to solve a lot of problems because if they're month to month,
there's no commitment. There is zero commitment. Okay.
I do a six month contract and it's a 30 day notice of cancellation type of thing.
So it's like, yeah. So Rudy, I don't like sharing them with other people.
I like to give them to one company because again, it comes back to this.
If I can get a business owner to make money,
I know I'm going to close that business owner. Like I better close that business owner.
So I prefer to just give two or three leads to one person and just focus on that one person.
What I found is when you start sharing the leads, like this guy gets it,
this guy gets it, this guy gets it, and you kind of do the round robin,
the lead gets overwhelmed. The lead's like, what is this? They're confused.
And the person that closes the job might not be the person that you want to work with.
So I like to just find the person I want to work with, hook them up,
make them money and make it work. Okay. That's just my two cents. You can.
I've done it not on purpose. I have done that before.